[Music]
the kod challenge recently Stan pranon
Sensei hosted a request on iido Journal
uh asking people's different opinions
about kotagi and um one of the problems
that arises with kotagi which is uh when
I'm applying the technique is it
possible for UK to come around and smash
me in the jaw um so first let's just go
ahead and look at the technique I'm
going to show from shui I think it's a
nice position to start
from
okay so that's the basic technique of
shui uh in that we came we started from
this position I go to the outside which
is a nice safe movement I come as Mike
starts to come around I'm going to apply
public I to him now here's where we
start to see the problem Mike can
possibly strike me here uh and the first
question um that Sensei asked was
um could uh should we allow luk to do
this in my opinion we should for the
practice of iido because this is a safe
position for him to take the fall from
you can see here Mike nicely sets up for
a high fall he's in good position he's
safe and everything set up really nice
for him so I think that's the easiest
thing for Mike to do also one of the big
misnomers about kot is kage makes people
take a high fall that's incorrect kage
puts a lot of torque on this wrist and
if Mike doesn't take a high fall or
otherwise relieve the pressure in his
wrist it's going to damage his wrist so
Mike chooses to take the high ball and
because I'm a good N I want to let him
take that high so it's safe for him okay
can C gu should be applied in ways that
keeps that from happening if the timing
of my technique is such that I can come
right back here I can possibly apply
that technique so Mike cannot come
around to strike me um and this is find
in a form and we could always practice
it in the form this way but when we're
doing it in a live situation where I
don't know what Mike's up to and he
might be attacking me in all kinds of
different ways there's no guarantee that
that's going to happen and so it's quite
a real possibility that when I apply
this code of gu no matter how will I
like it might can still come around and
smash me in the face or grab me or do
something badly um so now we need to
really ask a bigger question I think
which is why would I apply K in the
first place uh am I applying KAG to
throw M if the answer is that if I want
to just throw Mike that's the big deal
and so he gets this kage position as
Mike comes around a better option for me
is to throw Mike over my hip it's going
to be a higher percentage throw for me
it's going to throw Mike in a nicer way
it's going to put us in a control
position really quickly I would rather
do that so as M comes around and punch
me in the face why not just get out of
the way of that I can set up a nice hip
toss here and that would be a much
better idea than trying to apply the
CTIC iish um could the the question be
uh or the answer be that I'm applying
CTIC I to create a lot of pain in Mike's
wrist right so I make him think twice
about wanting to fight me because I
create so much pain in his wrist well
creating pain is is what I want to do
with Mike why not punch him in the nose
so if the technique went like this as
Mike comes around why not do this right
right why not punch Mike before Mike
gets a chance to punch me and in that I
can cover and protect myself from uh
Mike hitting me uh so a good reason that
I might need to apply K is if Michael
has something in his hand so if he has a
KN in his hand he's coming down to cut
me with the shui right he's coming right
in the front of my head and I stop him
here I cut to the outside now if I let
go with his hand and punch him he's
going to cut me okay if I try to throw
him in this here like's going to be able
to cut me you can see right here is
coming in to cut me so that's dangerous
I have to control that weapon so we're
here in this position as I come out I
come here and now I'm covering his hand
right this classic K position covering
his hand it's very hard for Michael to
remove the weapon from his hand here and
as he comes around even if he hits me
what I'm going to manage to do is get
the knife from M and when I get the
knife then I don't even care if it hit
me cuz I'm now in the superior position
with the weapon so the weapon's taking
precedent and this is an old idea of
kuchi where if he strikes me I want to
be able to cut him right
and US said that this wasn't the idea
BYO so we can talk about more stuff from
that also so let's say that as we do
this might comes around to strike me are
there other ways to deal with this as
might comes into strike I can use my
elbow to defend myself I can also strike
Mike with this as it comes in if I get
the pass I can also go into other IO
techniques from here like juj net so
this weapon control doesn't mean that I
can't still account for that hand if it
comes in there's lots of ways to take
care of that hand and still apply the C
G also as I take this in I can apply put
the Gish in a way that breaks the blade
towards M which makes him get out of the
way even if I don't disarm now we're in
a position that I can take him
over start to
control and remove the weapon so I think
uh if we're really going to ask this
question about the validity of kodish as
a Technique we have to consider things
outside of pure unarmed methods uh if
we're unarmed I would way rather use uh
a hip toss or just punching someone uh
Supply K but when we're talking about a
weapon it's a much more serious Affair
and I have to keep control of that
weapon hand so I have to find ways to
defend myself and keep control K the is
an excellent technique for keeping
control of the weapon and being able to
take care of this guy at the same time
I'm Chris H this is Michael Baron thank
you very
much